Last slide I wanted to leave you with,
which is sort of coincidence,
CEO pause a tarp,
fun because it will bomb some and exalt others is the one thing that I could
learn from psychedelics that seems secure over all the decades and the,
you know,
embracing one idea,
one in theology after another.
The one thing that seems secure is a truth that is hard to hear in the context
of a dominator culture with the obsession with the material world and,
and that truth is that nothing lasts,
nothing lasts.
You know,
your enemies will fade,
your friends will fade,
your fortune,
your poverty,
your disappointments,
your dreams,
everything is in the process of changing into something else.
So your agony is about to be a suede.
On the other hand,
your happiness is about to be destroyed.
So the,
the obligation that comes out of this realization is an obligation to the date
of the immediate moment to this thing that I've been calling the felt moment of
immediate experience.
It isn't who you were or what you were,
or who you will be or what you will be.
It's the felt moment of immediate experience.
And this has been robbed from a spike media and by our tendency to denegrade
ourselves to see the world in terms of the great ones,
not here,
whoever they are,
Aristotle,
Madonna,
Jesus,
whatever your particular band is.
Um,
the overcoming of neurosis,
of unhappiness,
of toxic lifestyles is,
uh,
the felt presence of the media experience in the bonding in the moment.
And you know,
psychedelics sexuality,
guess draw on the main sport,
dance.
These are the things which puts you in the felt presence of the moment.
And that's really all you ever possessed.
Your memories are eroding away.
The futures you anticipate will mostly not come to pass.
And the real richness is in the moment.
And it's not necessarily some kind of be here now feel good thing because it
doesn't always feel good,
but it always feels,
it is a domain of feeling.
It's primary language is not,
the primary ideology is not primary.
The propagation of future and past vectors is not primary.
What's primary is the felt,
the presence of experience of that is the source of love.
And that is the source of community.
Yeah.